hey it's pretty again and I'm back with
the ask pretty series and this is week
number two this week's question is a
very interesting one and one that I
actually get pretty commonly and so
let's go ahead and read it he says I've
been teaching myself to code for almost
a year now I initially started from free
code camp and other tutorials the more I
learn about web technologies like
JavaScript the more I want to learn
lower level languages like C++ a part of
me wants to go back to college to study
computer science I've done a little bit
of research and many seem to say that
it's not necessary but I want to be
marketable for a career in software
development I have read that the
industry is being flooded with junior
developers that don't know enough to be
productive so I suppose that is why I
think I need to go back to school I had
been applying to companies that fit my
skillset and I haven't had received one
response regarding an interview I'd
really appreciate your advice on whether
I should bite the bullet and go back to
college or just keep getting better at
JavaScript and web technologies like
react and angular this is actually a
very common question I get I'm actually
one that I also had when I was getting
started with programming and I'll kind
of start off by saying that there's
really no silver bullet answer per se
because it really just depends on you
and honestly your circumstances your
timing obviously and all that and what
you can afford but I can show you kind
of my decision process for how I thought
through this decision of whether I
should go back to college if I want to
become a programmer and I kind of
outlined my decision process in my blog
post on why I left the best job in the
world so if you want a more detailed
explanation of how I thought through
this you can read that blog post but
let's just get started so I felt that
for me I was already in a full-time job
right and so for me I felt like if
there's any way to learn to for me to
learn the skills of becoming a
programmer without going back to college
I was 100% for it and the reason is
because for one it's way cheaper right
like if I go back to college the tuition
for college is what like anywhere
between 10 20 40 K here and I already
had paid off I already had a four-year
degree so I paid off already like
$90,000 and
student loans and I was like I really
don't want to take what I take out loans
to go to college again and secondly it's
it's I wanted a faster path when I want
something I really really want something
and I want it right away and I really
have the patience to wait two three four
years to get a degree and then become a
programmer I wanted the fastest path and
and the most efficient path to get there
and so before I made the decision what I
did was I reached out to a ton of people
and did a lot of research on this right
so first I met with a bunch of people
who hadn't the traditional path and they
had a C s degree and I kind of talked to
them and talked to them about how they
got to what their first job was like how
they had they made that transition from
school to getting their first job and so
forth and then I met a bunch of people
who were more the non-traditional path
who were either self-taught went to boot
camp or both and and I kind of talked to
them about their process for how they
kind of broke in to become become a
software engineer and at the end of this
whole research process what I realized
was yes there's a lot of people who take
it to take the traditional path of
getting a computer science degree but
there's also hundreds or thousands of
people who are totally totally killing
it without a degree top of my mind some
examples of people who I really look up
to who fit in this bucket are like Dan
Abramov who's the creator of redox or
Paul Irish who now works at Google or my
really good friend has seen Qureshi who
was a poker player turned software
engineer just like countless examples
that I saw in the industry and what's
common amongst all these different
people were that they were passionate
they were determined and they were smart
and at that end they just wanted this
really badly and they figured out a way
to do this without the degree so I was
like okay if these people can do it I
can do it too
right and I think when you're kind of
making this decision it's important to
just be honest with yourself and so when
I look back and think through why I
think I might have been successful
without the degree is you know there's a
few different reasons I can think of one
is that I kind of already had a
technical background so in college I was
a systems engineer
and I you know because of that I took a
lot of pretty heavy high-level math and
engineering courses so I already like I
was already kind of trained to think by
analytically it was very good with math
and very good with numbers but that's
not to say that you need a technical
degree to be a developer I think I know
plenty of people who studied like
philosophy or psychology in college and
then later on in life realized they want
to be developers but for me like I think
that was one of the reasons why I was
pretty successful in this transition and
second I was obviously extremely
passionate about it and and I kind of
conveyed this passion throughout various
blog posts ever in and I just wanted
this so badly and I think because I
wanted so badly I was incredibly
determined I worked really hard and I
put I put a lot a lot of time and effort
into making this reality happen and you
know along the way I did have to give up
and sacrifice a lot like for example I
didn't see my family for almost a year
during the process I didn't see a lot of
my friends for many many months I was
pretty much doing this day out day in
and day out just learning how to code
every single day getting a little bit
better at it and even you know even my
boyfriend I didn't see for life you know
I saw him once a week which is like
really really hard obviously but you
kind of I was kind of willing to give up
these things because I knew that I
wanted this dream to come true so badly
and I think this might motivate some
people so early on in my decision
process I was talking to a really good
mentor and you know he was he's this
kind of highly academic person who has
the C s degree and he has a PhD in
computer science you know went to
Stanford so very academic and I was kind
of telling him about my decision to go
become a software developer and I was
kind of saying like hey like I don't
know like one thing I'm worried about is
how will I ever catch up with these
people who've been programming since
they were 12 years old they literally
have like a decade of experience over me
it may be even a college degree and what
he said he looked at me in the eye and
he's like what I see in you is great and
passion you're gonna get there in no
time just just go for it
and when someone like that said that to
me someone whose academic it has a
degree and he just like he's like no you
can do it without it like just go figure
it out it's all about just doing and
that really was inspiring to me and I
was like okay I can do this without the
degree and kind of to address his
question of you know the industry is
being flooded with junior developers
that don't know enough to be productive
I totally I've heard this too there's
definitely a lot of people who are
trying to get into the industry more
than ever now and you know everyone kind
of wants to be software developers it
seems and sure there's probably a lot of
developers out there who are simply not
ready for full-time jobs and maybe
they're getting hired but they're not
being productive and but you know like
as I said there's plenty of examples to
show out there are people who are
totally killing it in the industry
without a degree the main thing to
understand though is that it's not easy
it just takes a lot of hard work and
there's really just no shortcuts not
getting a degree it doesn't mean that
you take a shortcut it simply means that
you work really really really extra
extra hard to kind of make up for that
lack of degree right you can't just
expect to maybe take a course online or
attend to cheat three months boot camp
or take like you know like an online
boot camp like Udacity or something and
then all of a sudden magically have a
job you can do all those things but
that's just one part of the process and
in addition to that you have to put
hours and hours of practice and work and
and really just make up for that time
that you didn't spend in school getting
a degree and so to not be one of those
people who are you know not being
productive in the industry you just need
to go above and beyond and every person
I know who's successful in the industry
that doesn't have a degree they're
successful because they've put these
hours and dedicated their lives to
making this reality come true
so again if you're willing to put the
hard work then you honestly just won't
be one of these developers who's not
productive I actually have never met
someone who's worked that hard and and
and like didn't get better over time or
wasn't the one of the better best
programmers I've ever met right and even
if it takes you longer to get there than
some others just don't compare yourself
to other people it's just
about putting in the hours putting in
the time practicing coding getting
projects on your under your belt like
you know it's frustrating like the first
few months are very frustrating just
keep trying keep trying and overtime
like you'll look you'll look up and
you're like oh my god I just know so
much how did I get how did I even get
here right and I think if I have to go
back and think one of the hardest part
about not taking this path of not
getting your degree is probably getting
your first interviews and getting your
first job because you don't have you
don't have any experience you don't have
anything to show that you you can call
it basically and so what I would do like
as I said in my last video if you don't
have something like if you don't have a
degree if we don't have experience don't
focus on what you don't have show them
everything else that you do got so this
can be this can be like this can be like
side projects or this can be like
internships or this can be like open
source work that you've done or blog
post that you've written you just make
up for that lack of degree in other ways
right and another thing I want empathize
is if you choose to not get a degree one
thing that happened to me was I noticed
that like I was starting to I really
want to fill in my gaps of some of the
formal fundamental CS stuff like things
like computer networking operating
systems compilers algorithms and data
structures design patterns like these
are things I still wanted to learn
because I think those are very very
important to if we were gonna be a
serious offer engineer these are all
important things to learn and so what I
did was I would learn these things on
the side on weekends or nights just like
picking up a few books and just like
learning learning them on my own because
I really wanted to fill in those gaps
that I didn't get through formal
training and I actually have met with a
few companies now that are actually um
specifically targeting people who don't
have CS degrees but are software
engineers and they're teaching more of
these CS fundamentals like I met her the
school called Bradfield school of
computer science in San Francisco and
they teach things like you know computer
networking computer architecture
databases compilers so you know like
find something like this to fill in the
gaps if you don't get that formal
training and instead if you take more of
a online course or a bootcamp
and lastly the the writer who wrote in
said he wants to be a C++ developer
without a CS degree or is he's asking if
he should get a CS degree to be a C++
developer obviously I can't answer that
question cuz I've never tried that
myself I was a JavaScript developer and
I also did some API work and back and
work like I slowly moved down the stack
but my gut tells me is definitely
possible
perhaps there's less C++ content a lot
more content to learn online with
JavaScript Ruby or Python but I think
anything and anything in the world is
possible without a degree so if you if
you're confident that you can do it I
don't think you I'm never gonna say that
you must get a degree to do anything
because I just don't believe that but I
do want to say that just because I
didn't go back to get a CS agree because
it doesn't by any means mean that I
think a CS degree is a waste of time in
fact if I was in high school and I knew
what I know now about computer science
I'd probably do the computer science
degree over the systems engineering
degree that I did but you know like no
regrets at the time when I was in you
know 18 I really fell in love with
systems engineering
I loved my major so I have no regrets
it's just that I learned about computer
science a little bit later in life so I
didn't have a chance to take CS in
college but I think ICS degree if you're
still in high school is obviously
incredibly valuable and should totally
do it if you're in high school but it's
not game over if you haven't if it's too
late there's always ways to to learn how
to be a developer like I dated many
others have done so I want to close off
by saying if you want to be a developer
you just need to start doing you just
need to start building because being a
developer is not about sitting in a
classroom or taking exams or taking
tests or getting certificates or getting
a degree it's really about just building
software and if you can prove to people
that you can build software the degree
is just a tiny part of it and that will
soon be irrelevant in in the future and
and as I said there's just been
thousands of people who've been
successful without the degree and it
really just depends on how much effort
work and hard work you're willing to put
into this so yeah
that's kind of my rationale for why I
didn't take that path but I hope you
found this helpful and I'll see you in
next week's video